the Joe Rogan experience it's a
different it's a different world you got
Josie Aldo
you know you got max Holloway who's
walking around in 180 and get down the
last 45 that's his teammate what sounds
to be is a beat yeah oh my god man it's
a beat is a [ __ ] shot that's a
Shaolin monk oh he's amazing he they
gonna make a movie that guy they gonna
make a movie of him I was a beat yeah he
got a crazy story yeah like shaolin monk
type stuff sent him off as a kid type
thing really yes they listened zabi I've
never seen that like Sabae he's filling
him and training him his english getting
better too
it is good that's that's a good thing
for him like I think he he's the next
well man if so many stars brewing in
Dagestan it's there's so many of them
over there sure well that if they have
that mentality and they're that tough I
mean there's just that that breeds more
people like that you know
killers breed killers you look at like
Jim's like aka right you know you've got
Cain Velasquez Daniel Cormier age you
know go down the line you know Luke
Rockhold John Fitch and just Josh
Koscheck how many [ __ ] killers have
come out of that gym you got to see a
cabina and play basketball in Dagestan
when I was over there it's like one of
my most popular videos where they they
play basketball full game hours of
basketball and and train for two hours
and they know dribbling but doesn't
khabib have [ __ ] up knees what do you
mean by no dribbling it's called
dagestan basket please just hold onto it
like rugby basketball come on look at
this looking at it's the craziest thing
you just hold on yes yes no they trying
to wrestle they throwing you down like
people getting choked out like it's the
craziest thing ever this is the most
ridiculous be could be so sorry in
basketball Jamie Jamie lo this is a
little this is crazy
White Russian basketball yep on it look
at could be what happens look wrestle
yeah it gets intense - oh my I play with
them once
why don't they dribble I have no clue
look at
he and he intends to yelling at him they
probably play with a medicine ball now
they planted medicine ball heavy as hell
that is so ridiculous watching people
run around really badly look that is
hilarious
look it could be look we've scored look
look he looked at me he pointed it to me
he pointed to me like and they play for
hours
that's so in any like oh it's time to
Train it's time to Train now so that's
their warmup yeah that's the gym could
be training right now that's it that
floor yeah right now that's crazy the
fact look at you guys look the fact that
they they play a different version of
basketball yeah did you just get Kayode
what happened there oh man is look ship
at the end it is could be even like
choke somebody out like it's really yeah
it's crazy man they dating now and
they've run on the mats with their shoes
on these [ __ ] are gonna get
staff look look look look look it could
be what is happening here this is so
ridiculous yeah it's like rugby
basketball that's what I called it but
they call it a different thing in
Dagestan and I found what do they call
it here's something it's like Australian
rules football right like Dagestan is
literally and I'll play I'll play with
them and ice my my knee was swelled for
two days in Dagestan because they
tackled hard it was killing me compete
and look after after our China dribble
or just watch porn and everything but
when I'll kept getting my knee started
hurting Kabir was like brother you too
big to be sorry you twist your knee yeah
they was all arguing about picking me up
because I remember that when I dumped
Anka be if I sent you that that the
image of me Duncan on her like he's
trying to guard me yes they really
wanted to pick me up then it was like
are we getting him so I'm thinking is
gonna be easy I'm gonna just hold the
ball up and jump boy they was taking my
knees out he was taking it easy on each
other until they saw the black dude
when they saw the black goo played it
was like are we really not about that
guy who actually had the potential to
play profession 8 and they go on crazy
at this this is hilarious serious to
sketball
that's fun look if the balls look at
that every time I hit sticker yeah it's
got no bounce look he dimed him duh well
it looks like the floor is a regular
bounce it is look how happy they is look
at your dad
like that with the [ __ ] ball like
this is slow motion so you see look push
you out of bounds they do all that they
did that to me a couple times but they
run on that [ __ ] man watch this look
at this here it is right here watch this
look look look look look a bebang stop
it so he's wrestling with this dude why
is he doing that cuz to hold him down
like in out a wrestling rest and look
could be main stop it and they're doing
it on the map look look look Coby he's a
mad man oh my god he's taking us back
he's come out is the other tab it's
crazy so they wrestle the all their plan
boys yes they will tackle you down no
there's no rules no rules that is
hilarious
look the guy tapped a ready look and now
he's got him in an arm already tapped oh
man he's a bring back memories but wait
a minute
he's so you look man people trying to
get could be bought them yeah why is his
teammate because because you free up
another opponents so you can play but
that long could be he thought jock CJ
right there skyhook oh man that is crazy
MMA fighters playing basketball it's the
worst thing is is not basketball this is
something different
I mean when you're not ever dribbling
did you see the video Francis trying to
act he paid homage to Zion wasn't and
then he was out there shooting
basketballs you just did it bro
France is the worst athlete he's not
athlete but I'm sorry if you can't if
you six-foot-five and can't dunk a
basketball huh been well don't you
remember when Mike Tyson was in his
prime
with their overalls with the overall
watches he's got dedication and one
thing yeah that's the thing I mean look
oh my god
well that's probably the first time he
ever tried to do man
and he will punch you a pinkie and your
soul to come out to buy
[Applause]